welcome to our garden in nottingham i
just wanted to show you
three things which are pretty unusual
that we have lying around our house
two of them are connected with my
grandfather
joseph polyakov here he is
and this was when he was quite old the
age i remember him
he was born four years after mendeleev
proposed the periodic table
so a long time ago and the other object
is a really interesting thing that was
produced
by my father-in-law my wife's father
john keane who was an excellent health
physicist
well you can see that my grandfather had
hair
that was much better behaved than mine
and he was a fantastic inventor always
inventing things
and he got really cross that when he
used the comb
as he combed his hair the comb got
charged with static electricity
so the hairs started standing up so this
isn't a problem
for me but he found it really irritating
and he invented a solution and this
is his solution it is a plastic comb
but it has the back is conducting
metal so that when an electric
charge started to build up it would
discharge itself
through the metal so he could comb away
this is the first time i've ever combed
my hair on film
he could comb away and not charge up his
hair
i think he patented it but nobody was
really interested in it
the second invention is
something i have no idea exactly what it
was for
perhaps one of you can tell me
it's basically a pair of spectacle
frame so i put it on grandfather
and then explain to you what it is it's
already slightly broken but
so it's a pair of glasses frame here
and underneath is a very narrow
tube one ending under each nostril
and when i first got it there was a
rubber tube
at the end of the metal one which
presumably went up your nostrils
and then down here is another rubber
tube
connected to some sort of union
so something was either pushed up here
or sucked up there into your nose
and i have no idea what it was for it
may have been for some sort of
cranky medical treatment it might be
something much more sophisticated
professor how come you've got this and
how did you get it
i think it was found when my parents
were clearing their house
and my father probably said martin you'd
like to have this take it
and i've had it ever since
so i'd really like to hear from any of
you who can think what this might be for
[Music]
the third object on the face of it
looks a bit boring it's a block of
plastic
particularly a block of the plastic
called perspex
or plexiglass but what's interesting
is what's inside it or alternatively
what's not inside it
john keane my father-in-law
built in about 1969 a very powerful
electron accelerator this was for
cancer study and treatment and if you
put
a block of perspectives like this in
front
of the electron accelerator pulses of
electrons hit it
and it charges up to a huge voltage and
then
and this is the exciting part if you
take a simple thing like a screwdriver
and touch it
all the electricity discharges
essentially
like a miniature lightning spark
but what's amazing is that as the spark
comes
out it destroys the plastic
and so you get frozen inside it
what is known in the trade as a perspex
tree
but essentially is a frozen lightning
spark
i think they look absolutely amazing
what do you do with that one professor
it's just an ornament
we keep it on the chimney piece above
the fireplace
but i have seen similar ones
at an institute in germany where
they were being used as the door handles
for the visitors hostel where the
visitors
including me stayed
[Music]
you